it's probably one of the more gruesome
deaths of all which again i go back to
like she didn't deserve it
[Music]
olivia died a very sad death in my
opinion because i can't figure out why
she deserved it in the first place
honestly i feel like she was a sweet
girl she needed some humbling maybe in
there but you know she didn't deserve
death
she was next door to jill and kirby and
jill and kirby were
watching shawn of the dead together they
gave me a call invited me to come up
there was no way i was coming up i
didn't want to have anything to do with
jill
considering her cousin in that whole
situation so trevor
then calls jill jill gets a phone call
says it's from trevor but it's not
really trevor
so it's this ghost face voice and of
course kirby who answers the phone for
her doesn't believe that this is ghost
face she's kind of playing around until
ghostface says i know you're watching
shawn of the dead and that's when things
get really real that's when the girls
know
okay he knows what we're watching this
is definitely not trevor at this point
so kirby is brave you know her brave
self and she's like
wanting to figure out who this is and
show yourself to me
and ultimately ghost space says i'm in
the closet so
herbie walks up to the closet and
bravely opens it ghostface is not there
to which she says i'm not in your closet
and that's when next door you see olivia
morris just get totally taken down by
ghost face she puts up a pretty good
fight though i'm not gonna lie like she
gets stabbed in the hand and thrown
around and all of that but she
ultimately gets
uh stabbed in the stomach several times
and is completely gutted and it's
probably one of the more gruesome deaths
of all which again i go back to like she
didn't deserve it but hey
that's what happens you know
we think she would have become a
psychologist based on all of the traumas
that she's gone through in her life you
know i feel like people they
they go through to do that self-healing
journey and ultimately they end up
helping others
in her ways of trying to make sense of
jill's
logic for killing all her friends and
family because her boyfriend cheated on
her i think she probably would have
become a psychologist
made by trader joe's i don't know the
exact name of it but it's a specific
type of granola
and they're these little circles and
they have cranberries in them and then
these little pellets of random things
and i still eat them today that's where
my
journey with those began and pretty much
everybody close in my life knows that
those are like a staple piece for me